e
cosa voglia
[Musica]
by cos'è
cazzo ho preso la mia gamba
cosa devo fare qui devo uscire
porca [ __ ] toglierla perché non
faceva troppo casino smettetela di
chiamarmi quando lavoro ok questa è la
perfetta la stanza
cazzo era devo riuscire allora devono
calcolare bene i tempi
[Musica]
[Applauso]
non ci credo non ci credo
c'è ma io mi giro così poi non me lo
trovo davanti ok ok ok
site la stringo volentieri la mano ma
non adesso
ma dopo dio cos'era
va beh qualcosa prima
porca [ __ ] via alla ragazze devo
riuscire a tagliare il cranio di questa
povera vite di questo povero paziente
ora devo riuscire a tagliare
o sbagliato oddio salvina olè olè olè
olè olè ce l'ho fatta bene e che cosa
dovrei fare qui adesso devo uscire di
fano è chiusa bene alla mia [ __ ]
finestra
grande gli occhio dai che jerry cos'è
madonna mia un criceto farebbe di più
vaio
ma che cazzo dice allora fatemi prendere
sto cazzo no no ho un mio addio
sull'occhio ho capito cassetti pollo e
tre stella devo fare tipo 1 a due tre
stella ok ci sai giocare al suo gioco ci
sei giocare bravo e direi di proseguire
rag allora andiamo avanti
[Musica]
mangiatelo mangiatelo ghini mangiatelo
guardate che botta s'è preso cos'è
paranormal organi è una disco gallina
kong
[Musica]
e vi ha dato l'autorizzazione di
famiglia gara a torto
ma solo io li trovo
porca [ __ ] [ __ ] ai così grandissimo
cos'è che ci sta cagando un piccione
dentro se la bandiera che culo vai vai
deve mai
una volta che visto il rigiocarsi giochi
mi prendo la botta raga che cazzo girati
marcia [ __ ] cos'è sta roba
ecc oddio e che cosa è bruciato
no niente niente niente niente niente
allora devo capire stare calmo devo
stare calmo e capire come andare avanti
niente perché mi dimentico di andare a
destra cazzo e vai col laser devo
riuscire no no io mica se si accende se
no
gli ho fatto un tatuaggio sulla fronte
allora ragazzi possono segnare la mia
pizza
[Musica]
morire le ruches che cazzo
alziamo le mani dei turni so ma è così
taglio ma le dita no
è partito un po maledizione che cazzo si
è aperto
ieri qui mia figlia poi banco al basket
oddio cos'era ma come fare a prenderla
parla coi piedi spiega me lo spiega meno
brutto
teoria sangue dovrebbe venire la sosta
che cazzo
ok merda raga
[Musica]
fatality vai cos'è cos'è cos'è sta roba
vj preferisce la patata o la nutella
vediamo se stavolta ci hanno azzeccato
andiamo sulla patata allora vediamo se
bravi e non mi chiedete perché devo dar
fuoco a quella roba perché ancora non
l'ho capito
oddio
non ho esperienza quei cervelli ma so
aprire le uova se è più o meno la stessa
cosa allora siamo a cavallo
la possiamo fare ma porca [ __ ]
leicester ok no oil cazzola il laser
merda raga laser selvatico nello studio
merda a iotta ragazzo
sta segando il paziente a metà il mio
polso better place is on the table
se mi sparano il copyright sono cazzi
sono cazzi vostri
mi dovete spiegare come fa uno a guidare
in queste condizioni c'è già una gamba
in bocca praticamente che cazzo fa
andiamo avanti qua ci sono delle punte
che devo saltare non ce la faccio
non ce la faccio 6 perché perché sei un
pezzo di merda se non sai saltare cazzo
devo soltanto riuscire a capire che il
cazzo devo farci ok c'erano
solo perché esiste
porca [ __ ] cos'è sta roba ok ragazzi
sono ci sono
[Musica]
ci sono no
guardate guardate liuc guardate
attentamente luke raga c'è parte e poi
lo ri figlio
cosa cazzo ti compare in un modo che non
certo non c'erano ben
comparire così allora ragazzi prima cosa
bisogna lasciare l'orologio in un posto
dove non dà fastidio
beh oddio
[Musica]
senti zio ho trovato una lettera mi dai
una mano
porca [ __ ] [ __ ] non la matita mi
serve per filmare il cuore quindi quella
mi serve ancora e già che ci sono di
firmo il polmone fa vj
oddio cosa stanno
già cro bat non c'è non ho veramente se
riescono ma guarda te cioè io sto visto
lasciando e riprendendo con la diana in
una maniera assurda cioè sono senza
gambe tra l'altro ma non voglio neanche
sapere dove dove cielo infilata la liana
oddio
troppo le scarpe ho trovato buongiorno
sono sue come faccio incollarla a
qualcuna dell'attak in sala operatoria
malizia allora ora ce la posso fare 34
die die zeit e
io ci credo
[Musica]
guarda brutto bastardo comelico guarda
guarda ho vinto brutto stronzo vinto io
ok però
gioca
[Musica]
[Applauso]
nota
[Musica]
la casa
ahi ahi ahi ahi ahi fermi un attimo
poiché ai ragazzi ci sono ragazzi tenevo
a prendermi questa piccola parte alla
fine del video perché volevo
ringraziarvi di cuore per il 50 mila
iscritti che poi adesso sono 55mila
praticamente raga un traguardo assurdo
incredibile ragazzi vi ringrazio
veramente di cuore non so veramente i
ora che ogni volta non trova le parole
perché ogni volta prime te non ci credo
che siete così tanti dio mio grazie
veramente di cuore ragazzi siete i
migliori non trovo veramente le parole
grazie infinite in occasione di questo
traguardo incredibile ho voluto
aggiungere diciamo delle novità e quindi
di reni di elencarle subito così non
perdere tempo allora la prima è che
adesso che è finito maggio e quindi
diciamo sono più libero dai compiti
perché maggio è stata una cosa infernale
se vi siete divertiti questo mezzo a
vedere i miei video sappiate che dal
prossimo sarà una cosa assurda perché mi
sono tenuto l'essere migliori per giugno
perché a maggio praticamente o arrancato
tra virgolette come potevo perché non
avevo mai tempo ea giugno sarà a partire
da giugno per l'estate mi sono tenuto le
serie migliori quindi ragazzi
aspettatevi di tutto è la seconda novità
è che non ci saranno più speciali ogni
5000 iscritti ragazzi perché
praticamente li stiamo raggiungendo ogni
settimana e fare uno speciale settimana
raga e straziante non avete idea di
quanto tempo mi tolgo a fare uno
speciale ci impiego veramente tantissimo
adesso raga sto pensando di farli ogni
10.000 iscritti più o meno adesso non ho
ancora deciso
ma comunque dato che cresciamo in una
maniera incredibile state tranquilli che
usciranno molto spesso quindi raga non
ne farò più di 5.000 iscritti ma circa
ogni 10.000 comunque di speciali a ogni
evento ci saranno state tranquilli ma
non è finita qui adesso in avanti
usciranno anche a sorpresa quindi raga
ogni tanto aspettatevi all'improvviso
uno speciale così dal nulla perché ci
saranno a sorpresa dato che d'estate
ovviamente ogni tanto quando tempo
libero di sicuro li faccio e come
speciale oltre momenti epici dei
videogames ci tenevo a fare un qualcosa
in più diciamo per il 50 mila iscritti
che simbolicamente sono un traguardo un
po più importante degli altri e cosa
avrei mai potuto aggiungere come
speciale di uno speciale avrei potuto
fare un video cugino più piccolo allora
adesso giochiamo aziende
ma qualcosa non andava quindi ragazzi
dopo averci pensato per secoli su cosa
fare me lo avevate chiesto in tantissimi
continuato a chiedermelo in tantissimi e
nonostante io l'abbia fatto continuerete
a chiederlo in tantissimi spero di no
vabbè ragazzi me l'avete veramente
chiesto in tanti quindi alla fine ho
dovuto farlo mi avete costretto quindi
ragazzi godetevi l'harlem sheikh
con lo terrorizza
tutti
di chi
li mortacci vostra
è beccate visto un nuovo finale
però non mi aspettavo
oddio sono esploso